only on Adult Swim in 2006 that you'd
want to want I made a short called the
real animated adventures of doc and
Marty don't be sad Marty we'll go back
in time and we'll make sure that your
kite doesn't get stuck in the dream all
right Doug that sounds great I had
fallen in love throughout the course of
making that cartoon with the voices of
the two characters I kept using those
voices and things I'm trying to do
science in the basement Mitch Harmon
calls me and he's like hey Adult Swim is
asking me about an animated project do
you have anything like do you have any
ideas I'm like well what about you know
what about those characters I think we
got as far as an animatic and and the
animatic went over to Cartoon Network
and the thoughts coming back were this
is great in this way in that way and
that way and by the way I think we
should cast Morty I don't think Justin
should do both voices I just felt wow I
don't like Morty I really like Rick but
while Morty's funny for a couple minutes
I'm gonna get really tired of this that
was initially read as could you recast
Morty and I was like [ __ ] okay cuz like
I knew for me a big part of the show was
like riffing back and forth with the
carrot you know doing both characters so
justin was terrified I know Justin was
freaked out Harmon gave me really good
advice he's like let's just let's just
see this through and let's let's see
what happens we auditioned just a
billion people
I remember we submitted our top three
and Lazar didn't like any of them he was
like these are all just as bad and we're
really okay we got to get on the phone
last oh I dreaded that phone call cuz I
was like man now I'm thinking and this
is it because like everything's gonna
fall apart
Michael as I was on the phone and I
haven't worked with him that much and he
gets to the meat of it which is like you
know it's not it's not the voice it's
the fact that the character is such a
punching bag
he was designed to be a stupid machine
so that Rick could cuss at it that's
okay for five minutes but if you're
gonna make ten half hours it's not gonna
work on that call I said listen let me
let me take another crack at the
character and he's like that's fine go
for it I started work shopping scenes
Harmon wrote me an email with like all
these little paragraphs so all of these
scenes need to illustrate him standing
up to Rick you know because that never
happened in the original pilot script
not once and one of them was there in a
flying car and Rick is drunk and he's
gonna destroy the world with a I get a
call at like 8:00 in the morning I wakes
me up and it's [ __ ] four one five
area code I'm like oh [ __ ] this is Adult
Swim so I answer it and it's Lazo and
he's like all right
I watched the I watch the stuff all
right you you got that you got it you
can do Morty and I'm like [ __ ] okay
holy [ __ ] Morty to me is one of the
deepest characters of the show now
because he has to deal with the most and
he in essence is the audience you know
when I watch Rick morning I am Morty
it's funny because it's like it was one
of the worst crises to happen in the
history of Rick and Morty's development
the potential of Justin not doing both
voices and it was the greatest thing
that happened it was this final puzzle
piece I mean listen it is it is humbling
to see how big this machine is has
gotten like there are times where I'm
like whoa I got myself into you started
out as me making dumb cartoons with my
friends in my apartment and now it's me
making dumb cartoons with hundreds of
amazing people you know I've seen some
of the episodes ten times they don't get
old I mean that's the basis of great
entertainment I want to see it again I
mean it really is cool to think back
about how it all began
the best thing about it is that it
proves a certain religion right which is
be yourself work with your friends don't
tell jokes that don't make you laugh
don't tell stories that don't make you
cry and everything else is gonna come
out in the wash
otherwise what good is capitalism if it
can't figure out what's awesome
you know babbling at the end I can't
even do my [ __ ] documentary interview
right
hey everybody new Rick and Morty they're
dropping all kinds of promos before the
finale and talking about how it all got
started but the cool thing about this
promo is a lot of you might have
realized that it sounds familiar because
they talked about it on the commentary
track for the first episode so that's
the whole reason for buying the DVDs
which is probably what I'll do the
giveaway for once the season's over we
don't actually know when that's gonna
drop but it's usually about six months
after the season's end but if you are
new to my channel be sure to subscribe
to get everything the finale is gonna be
crazy this weekend so there's a whole
bunch of cool stuff that you actually
get from this you want you get Mike
lazzo who's sort of like the Jedi Master
of Adult Swim if there's any Adult Swim
shows that you've loved in the last
several years chances are he's the
reason they're on the air so he's sort
of like the obi-wan Kenobi
to the young Jedi Padawan that are
Justin roiland and Dan Harmon depending
on how you feel about it but the big
story is that Justin roiland almost
didn't do the voice of Morty and they
had to retool the show just a little bit
because when they first pitched it to
him there was a lot more oh geez Morty
in a lot less assertive Morty I hear
that jeez I guess I'm supposed to be
figuring out who robbed the store across
the street but ah jeez I don't know geez
man that sucks that you're Rick's making
you do that he's not my Rick he's my
partner geez so that's why the intro for
that first episode plays the way it does
where he takes over the ship and has to
land it because Rick gets too drunk to
show him as more of a counterbalance
rather than someone that Rick actually
just takes around with him because of
the morty waves which is probably one of
the best explainers for why he's with
Rick even though it's not completely
true what are you talking about Rick
Rick's have a very distinctive and
traceable brain wave
our genius the best way to hide from an
enemy's radar is to stand near someone
with complimentary brainwaves that make
ours invisible see when a Rickett is
with a Morty
the genius waves get canceled out by the
waves but the other cool thing about
this is that you get a better look
behind the scenes if you've never been
to the rick and morty offices which most
people haven't this is actually what the
writers room looks like although this
isn't everybody that works on the show
this is actually a picture of the whole
crew watching the finale justin roiland
posted last night
wall-e was staying up trying to get
himself a Super Nintendo which I guess
wasn't successful it's so fun to watch
them get psyched up about stuff in real
life like Dan Harmon gets really psyched
up about Game of Thrones Justin roiland
gets really psyched up about video games
but let me know in the comments how do
you guys feel about all the extra bonus
content they've been dropping for
episodes this year this is normally
stuff you would see them do for the DVD
like they would have some special
feature at first of the episodes but I
think it's really cool they've been
posting these as the episodes have been
dropping but like I said with those
special stories where they talked about
how things came together behind the
scenes that's really the reason why you
buy the DVDs so you get those
commentaries and some of the stories are
a little bit funnier than others
sometimes they get really drunk when
they're doing the commentaries it was
even one part way through season one
maybe it was season 2 where Justin got
so drunk and said something that sounded
like it was really funny but might have
got them in a whole lot of trouble this
is one of our special edition redo
commentaries where we re-recorded the
commentary of this episode but Justin
was too drunk way too drunk
yeah and set some things that would
probably I mean I look I said things him
in trouble tongue-in-cheek but I did say
things you know across the line I went a
little little nuts about anything that
was said it's about the audience we
tried to strike a balance between oh
great peek behind the curtain the
curtain kind of falling but what will
happen is is because I wasn't expecting
this I have another Rick and Morty video
that I'll post this weekend before the
finale so just leave all your requests
in the comments below and if you haven't
seen my previous videos I will be doing
bonus video
each week while we wait for season four
to get here and I might try to do an
audience participation Q&A type video
after the finale - like I would normally
do for Game of Thrones but
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner Jonathan Sandlin please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details
there'll be a new round when I post new
Rick and Morty so you can click here for
more finale and you can click here to
learn all about Rick's wife thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
[Applause]